so what is the future of human
communication I am fascinated by the
synesthetic quality of language the fact
that we can encode ideas and images into
little vocal patterns and then transmit
those vocal patterns through time and
space language is the first synesthetic
wireless technology of inter subjective
communication language gives us the
capacity to step into the mind of
another to step into the world into the
consciousness of another P fo P but
language is still a crude instrument as
flow Barre wrote at the end of the day
language is like a cracked kettle on
which we tap crude rhythms while we long
to make music that will melt the star is
at the end of the day human beings have
this urge to exteriorize their
consciousness and they've experimented
with a diverse set of ways in which to
do this whether it's songs and lyrics or
poetry or art or cinema all of these
things reflect mankind's historical
drive to manifest his consciousness
outside of his mind in front of his eyes
to create a common coherent experience
where we can all experience a communal
POV a communal inter subjective space
where our separate minds can become one
now Terence Mckenna talks about the
brilliant capacity of the octopi of
communication right the octopi become
their meaning the octopi turn language
into something that is exteriorized and
can be visibly beheld Terence Mckenna
points out the astonishing footage that
has been captured of octopi in their
natural environments blending into their
environments becoming
one with the background so that they can
hide in plain sight so they essentially
become their intention language becomes
something visibly beheld they become
fair meaning right there where their
mind on their skin oh my god
so imagine them speculate them about the
future of human communication how on the
back of things like virtual reality and
augmented reality will essentially
synergize universes of our own
construction will essentially be able to
move into our imagination and
exteriorize the contents of our minds it
will transform the nature of
intersubjectivity because when you want
to be intimate with somebody you want
you to speak or write them a poem or
author them a song instead you'll be
able to invite them into your mind to
share the psychic landscapes of your
imagination as an actual exteriorized
space that a person can immerse
themselves and inhabits the octa-pie
points the way the octopi show that
biology has come up with an even richer
solution to convey meaning with an
organism that becomes its meaning the
future of human communication I believe
the future in which consciousnesses will
share meanings will be one of telepathy
will be one of inter subjective totality
where we will become what we will behold
we will become our meaning we will
trance transmit our insights into our
outside
the world will become the condensation
of human imagination
[Music]